well as nate mentioned getting students  back to the classroom is causing some  changes to ccsd's  food distribution starting today it will  no longer be happening at the elementary  school parking lot  students who are doing in-person  learning on their signed days will have  to  have the option to receive breakfast and  lunch meals at their school location  during the school day  one family says this change is already  causing a headache  that little bit of food that they do get  during the week  five days a week and then the extra  little bags they get on the weekend  that helps a lot of us families who  struggle month to month already with  food  okay so food distribution sites will be  available for all children ages  2 to 18 years of age monday through  friday except  holidays now this will be from 7 a.m to  11 a.m  at middle school parking lots and 10 a.m  to 2 p.m  at high school parking lots coming up at  5 00 hear what the superintendent has to  say  about the changes